d'ailleurs dédié vous montrer un truc
vous allez voir briller dans les dîners
c'est ce qu'on appelle un caractère
sexuel seront nathalie va cérébrale on
tend les bras et regarder ce qui se
passe c'est de coude sont collés
regardez ce qui se passe chez moi
les deux coups tu ne peuvent pas être
normalement chez une femme on peut faire
ça chez un homme on ne peut pas faire
pourquoi certains caractères sexuels
secondaires c'est l'angle entre les os
de l'avant-bras et du droit qui sont
différents chez la dame une chez l'homme
alors et parfois des exceptions ce que
je vous propose c'est de le faire en duo
qu'est vous le faites vous filmez vous
nous envoyez être on va trouver des cas
un peu étonnant
sans compter les skis faveur toi battant
mais signifie pas sur le pont je vais
commencer doucement sa part mis tout
voir je vais doucement
[Musique]
servian photos
du corps
mais c'est toi les reflex mais c'est
impossible
[Musique]
c'est le point
makhoukh
bon alors on recommence avec les robes
ce que thomas mann ici
georges sam wa hockey n'est pas tout
seul à porter des jarres chaque race au
pouvoir fait du georges chakra et
georges
avait créé une robe jaune était
magnifique enfin bref façon bijou
maintenant je porte ici des bijoux ap
monaco on fait bouffer son incroyable et
là c'est une petite bague messika
comment faire un bon anniversaire
à
gaza